Elise wrote in saying do you think that
one day will be socially acceptable for
men to wear dresses and other women's
clothing maybe even makeup my guess is
yes and the reason that I say that is if
you look even just back over the last
thousand to 1500 years of human history
many fashion conventions that today we
associate only with one gender were at
one point common for another high-heels
men were the first to wear high heels
and that became something that now is
obviously much more prevalent among
women in Western culture many different
societies had men wearing what we would
describe as skirt like garments although
they weren't actually called skirts
which now in Western society are
disproportionately more common among
women so the last thousand to 1500 years
tells it tell us that fashion norms
societal fashion norms can change
drastically and I would assume that yes
at some point things will reorganize
again and apparel that currently is
associated with one gender will become
associated with another or a gendered
clothing may become androgynous where
both genders partake right I'd like to
think also that we in some places in the
country are reaching a point where
cross-dressing kind of is already
acceptable of course I like here in
Boston I mean you can I guess you can go
out in public without any fear of
repercussions that you're going to be
beat up or anything
yeah I'd a wave hands out say yeah I
wouldn't go into Southie but yeah it
depends on what neighborhood the also
just depends on what part of the country
but I mean I got a question is more
broadly socially acceptable I know there
are places already where it's not really
a big deal I couldn't care less what
someone is wearing I'd comment more
about whether it's a climate appropriate
than anything else but I guess it would
be sort of blanket social acceptability
yeah I mean I would hope we're we're
getting closer to that point and
certainly I don't judge people right I'd
like to think that I don't judge people
for what they're wearing unless they're
wearing fur oh yeah well then that's not
that net has nothing to do a gender no
do you immediately judge individuals who
are wearing real real animal those those
Canada Goose jackets yeah I can't stand
those well is that because they have
goose feathers in them
I think they have down in them yes but
then they also have that lining around
the hood that comes from trapping
coyotes in this brutal way all I didn't
know and they're very very popular these
Canada Goose jackets are all over the
place oh I know that they're super
popular I looked them up some of those
jackets are like eight hundred dollars
yeah I had no idea that they were using
I mean I know feathers are very commonly
used in in jacket linings I had no idea
about this coyote skin thing yeah it's
pretty brutal well alright well I'm
gonna have to look into that thank you
to Elise thank you to Frankie thank you
to Tina
bonus show next david pakman.com slash
membership to sign up for membership get
instant access to the bonus show coupon
code
I voted 17 still works it will give you
a big discount off of membership